let's have a look at this question which
comes under the heading of horizontal
resisted motion it's quite a tricky
question number one because there's just
so much information to take in
uh it's not uncommon for us to get like
a big paragraph or a couple of
paragraphs of text that we need to kind
of tease out the important information
and form equations
that we need to do but secondly it's
also challenging because as you're about
to see
when we walk through different parts of
this question this is a question where
as often happens in reality there are
different models that need to be used
for different points in time or
different locations
that the scenario describes so um each
of that uh each of those different
challenges means we're going to have to
be mindful of particular things as we go
through the questions so
let's start by reading and then we'll
eat you know eat through it one bit at a
time
when a jet aircraft touches down two
different retarding
forces so that's just a word a phrase
that's often used uh
in place of resisting because the whole
idea is just there's something that's
slowing down here right and retarding is
just another common
physical word for that these two
different retarding forces combine
to slow it down if the aircraft has mass
m
kilograms and speed v then they tell you
the two retarding forces there's a
constant friction force of two m newtons
so let's just highlight that
constant frictional force of
2m newtons and also
and that's due to the brakes i should
say and there's also a force
of one on 10 000 mv squared newtons
due to the reverse thrust of the engine
so let's just unpack what's going on
here right there's
really the part of this that is the
resistance resistant motion that we're
used to
is this part here that is um in
proportion to the square of the velocity
so
the faster you're going um the more this
uh
acts to resist or [ __ ] your motion and
that's why you've got that v squared
term there
and the reason why is because this is a
reverse thrust of the ancients so
reverse thrust means that the faster
you're going the more it's able to push
that thrust in the opposite direction to
effectively slow you down and then you
also have this constant frictional force
of two m newtons
which in this model we're considering as
uh not changing doesn't matter how fast
you're going
the friction i guess of the brakes
against the plane
aren't going to change so that's why
there's no velocity term here in that
constant frictional force
the reverse thrust does not take effect
until three seconds after
touchdown okay so you can see
immediately before we go any further
right there is this situation of number
one the brakes
sort of um act on the plane to slow it
down
and then some time later three seconds
also this reverse thrust
also comes into play so there's going to
be at least two models going on here
the braking only version and then the
braking and reverse
thrust together version
let x be the distance in meters of the
jet from its point of touchdown so this
is what we're considering the point of
touchdown
is going to be our x equals zero
position
and let t be the time in seconds after
touchdown so our initial conditions are
wheels hit the ground so we're not
worrying about any of the stuff that's
happening in the air
hence it's a horizontal resisted motion
situation
okay now come the questions the jet's
landing speed is 72 meters per second
show that and then there's particular
numbers for velocity and also
for displacement at the instant the
reverse thrust of the engine
to take effect okay so let's think about
this for a second
we've got a landing speed um this here
which sort of aligns with what we said
let t be the time in seconds after
touchdown so
this is our initial speed as it were
initial
velocity in the forward direction i want
to know
um you know how or i want to show rather
i want to prove that the velocity will
reduce to 66
and i will have gone 207 meters
everything is
in meters per second here at the instant
that the reverse thrust of the engines
takes effect now i actually know what
that time is
based on what the question told me
because it says the reverse thrust does
not take
effect until three seconds after
touchdown and
t is the time in seconds after touchdown
then this instant
right here this is going to be time
equals
three so i'm going to keep that in mind
as i start to piece this together
right so let's write some actual working
down for ourselves
part a this first part of the model
is just for the uh the first three
seconds right after three seconds other
things
take over so the first thing i'm going
to write is 4
time being between 0 and
three so later on we're gonna have to
work out what happens after
time three so we'll get to that shortly
now for uh zero to three we only have
the brakes you remember the reverse
thrust hasn't kicked in yet
so i need to think about the force
that's acting on that and then how to
create some equations on the basis of
that
now if we just go straight back to our
good old newton's laws of motion we have
f equals m a the force is mass
times acceleration i actually should
write a capital m there because the
question has told us
it's it's sort of denoted capital m as
our mass of the aircraft so i'm going to
put that in as a
capital m so now because the question
tells me what the
particular force is on owing to the
brakes in that sort of initial zero to
three period i can write this as
minus two m i'm writing that negative
there of course because it's it's
slowing down the
acceleration is in the negative
direction because i'm traveling forwards
or the aircraft is anyway
so that gives me m and then i'm going to
write acceleration as x
double dot so you can see i have that
constant mass
that is a common factor on both sides so
therefore i'm going to divide through
by that mass that gives me x double dot
equals negative 2. okay now where can i
take this well you can see part a
it wants me to go towards velocity i
need a velocity function here
so to get from acceleration up to
velocity and keep in mind for part a
i'm thinking in terms of time i can just
do a straight uh
integration with respect to t we're not
always going to be integrating with
respect to time as you'll see later on
in this question
but this time for this particular
question that's relevant so let's go
ahead
and i'm going to even show oopsy daisy
because i'm going to be integrating a
bunch of times throughout all the
different parts of this question
and i am going to integrate with respect
to different things i'm going to write
this as
x double dot d t equals the integral of
negative 2
d t all right so that gives me
velocity i'll write that as v because
that's what the question has stated
as v equals particular value and you can
see my integral is just going to land me
here minus two plus c
okay now i know at the instant when i
land that's the initial condition um the
jet's landing speed is let's go back to
the question
72 meters per second so therefore i can
use that and
i also did mention i'm going to get a
bunch of integrals here so i'll call
this constant 1
and i'll just tag that as just a real
number
i'm now going to use that initial
condition t equals 0 to evaluate this
constant so i can say
t equals 0 implies v
equals 72 that's what i got from
this statement right here so therefore
i get let's see here 72 equals zero
plus that constant so that just excuse
me the constant this is going to happen
a bunch of times because i'm going to
try and choose convenient values for
myself when i'm integrating
so now i have an expression for v that's
equal to
minus 2t plus 72.
all right now i can already use this to
solve the first part of the question you
can see showing that v
equals 66 and i know what my value of t
is but
since i'm in an integrating mood i'm
just going to continue that because i
also need to know not just velocity
but also displacement so i'm going to go
ahead and integrate
another time so i'm going to say
integrating again
i'm going to get i put a colon there
instead
i'm going to get displacement is equal
to and when i look at the right hand
side
um that minus 2t is going to become
minus t
squared plus 72 t and then another
constant and i'll describe that
as a real number just to note it that
way and uh
like before i've got this initial
condition of
x equals zero so since i've got
t equals zero giving me x equals zero
you're going to see this is going to
happen a fair bit so i'm just going to
go straight to saying yep that's going
to give me the second constant
being zero once you substitute in zero
and then zero and then zero again
you just get c2 by itself okay so
therefore
i now have my i got my velocity equation
before and now i have my displacement
equation minus t squared plus 72
t full stop so now returning back to
this spot up here at the
instant the reverse thrust of the
entrance takes effect that's t
equals three i'm just going to
substitute that into my v
and my x equations and that will give me
the velocity
and the displacement so i'm going to say
now
when t equals 3
let's go velocity that's going to be
minus 2 lots of 3
plus 72 that's 70 to
take away 6 and i'm not skipping that
line because i already know what the
next line is going to be it's
66 as required and in the same way i'm
going to go
and substitute t equals 3 into my
displacement
equation so let's see i get minus 3
squared plus 72 lots of
3 i get the negative term in the back so
72 lots of 3
or 3 lots of 72 is 216.
take away 9 and that's the 207
that was also given to us in part a
okay handy dandy i have my uh my result
here as required
that if given this particular landing
speed i have this
this speed and this displacement once
the reverse thrust
kicks in